how is this happening right now
girl it's happening yep that's brianna
out and about at a london barber shop
with her boo asap rocky
a fan captured the video which marks
riri's first public outing with the
rapper since giving birth to her baby
boy just weeks ago
as asap is in the barber chair getting
his hair cut you can see rihanna rocking
stylish shades as she smiles and takes
pictures with the locals
[Music]
is this happening right now
as you can see riri brought the party
with her
the couple's appearance comes after asap
rocky revealed his hopes for his newborn
son with rihanna in an interview with
dazed the rapper says quote i hope to
raise open-minded children not people
who discriminate and i'm not trying to
describe a saint but realistically i
just want a cool child with cool
appearance the rapper went on to tell
the outlet that before nothing he wants
his children to never lose their
imagination no matter their age it's
amazing and i'm honestly truly blessed
real you know rihanna and asap announced
they were expecting in january and
before the beauty mogul gave birth a
source told e.t that asap and rihanna
are quote down to earth have similar
styles and couldn't be more in love and
happy about this next chapter
another source previously told et that
the couple who has been dating since
2020 has quote not left each other's
side since welcoming their son
saying quote they are over the moon
she's been looking forward to motherhood
for a long time this little boy is going
to have the best baby fashion
so
now that the baby is here and rihanna is
out and about the big question is can
the navy expect new music anytime soon
well on that note here's what reads to
et in february do you think this stage
in your life is going to inspire new
music
oh gosh you can't ever you know that's
why my fans love you you know because
you asked all the good questions
uh well
yes you're still going to get music from
me maybe a lullaby i could see you and
asap dropping demos in the studio oh my
goodness not a lullaby my fans would
kill me they waited this long for a
lullaby i'd never sleep with this music
we are grown yeah
[Music]